have you been excuse you
I know you ain't deaf boy I asked you a
question where have you been
I don't want to talk about it right now
Gail oh you work out why it is 2:00 a.m.
in the morning have you lost your mind
my mom I'm a grown-ass man oh right just
in the [ __ ] alone but once can I just go
out and do whatever I want to do that
doesn't involve you and just chill I'm
18 years old
then the [ __ ] alone down my life you
came yes hmm now if you want to eat the
food that I paid for
senior raising your Sideshow Bob looking
ass you're gonna have to follow by my
household rule does that understood I'm
on the move for this [ __ ] Oh give us
[ __ ] what you in the mood for Khalif as
long as you live in this house you will
follow my rules
sorry st. as long as I live here at the
fire yo stupid-ass rules fine I'm moving
the [ __ ] on out oh oh really
and where is your broke ass gonna go huh
your book this stupid-ass place my car
you driving around in you own you off am
I supposed to get around pray for rain
build an ark like no one to yet I don't
care I don't need any of [ __ ]
anyways mama hopes
no these are my clothes the clothes that
I have so generously loaned your
ungrateful ass you know what I'm about
done I think it's about time to eat
don't know the wrong mmm
[ __ ] is about to get real she trippin
man
Shane's serious my baby boy subject what
are you doing
yo man I was watching that you're
watching it listen to you I gave you
three weeks to find a job didn't trash
my place you're touching your dick you
need to get out yo man you stop trippin
dude on exactly this goddamn thing right
now I [ __ ] let me tell you
something Cleve I keep you two rules you
don't trash my place and you don't touch
my sister
and you trash my place no you're my
sister
watch the season hey yo yo yo yo get yo
man I got nowhere sabelli not my problem
but you know what your [ __ ] problem
is huh you want all the fun without any
of the responsibility and that's the
[ __ ] crawl so get the [ __ ]
no come on man come on come on come pay
something right now get done come on
sister
I'm [ __ ] mom yo what no that's not
listen hey no nice can do don't to say
[ __ ] yo yo Joe just just just apologize
and say sorry right you should take you
back in cuz I'm your baby boy I'm a baby
boy I'm a baby boy yo yeah I could do it
okay alright let's do it
oh oh sorry I'm sorry
wait monia come on there you go
hmm
learn your lesson yeah it's pretty rough
out there and when you don't have any
money or food to eat huh yeah yeah this
sucks mija
well no worries you're home now so uh
why don't you go get cleaned up and I'll
make you something hot to eat okay
sweetie
you know what the [ __ ] man were you
doing here Oh David
this is my new boyfriend we met about
two weeks ago and we've been together
ever since he should have seen him he
came in to the yoga place and he saw me
doing yoga he said that my downward dog
inspired him to join yoga oh so sweet
it is so nice having someone to finally
go do yoga with me since you won't do
yoga with me I mean he is like you know
the biggest guy in the place but that's
okay
I can't wait till you guys get to know
each other you're gonna be doing 11 I
should probably let you two use that
time right now huh are you hungry
yeah I meant I know you all know so yeah
how about you why are you late Jess
Hey